after the album came out that Friday you
got on Saturn our lives next night big
night
first Saturday after the election you
gara not just you guys but you're almost
Chappelle yes
Chappelle came out and did an incredible
open on that show I thought yes and one
of the things he said I'm gonna quote
him he said at the end he said I'm gonna
wish Donald Trump luck and I'm gonna
give him a chance and we the
historically disenfranchised demand that
he give us one - yes reciprocity right
I'm gonna give him a chance but he's got
to give us a chance so what do you think
about that about that statement and do
you feel like you're gonna give Donald
Trump a chance I guess we have no choice
but to give him a chance right because
he's the president but I think that you
know it's it's just a lot of heightened
probably dissing disillusionment with
him because he's been a public the
public figure for over 30 years the
platform that he ran on is one of is
very scary it's is it's extremely
polarizing it's divisive it's not
necessarily inclusive and it's dangerous
and this was one that brings about a
almost absolute fear so given those kind
of signifiers I don't know if given I
wouldn't want to give someone like that
a chance per se yeah but the the the
actuality of the situation is that he is
the president and people voted for
though I didn't vote for him he is the
incumbent and you know he's my president